ADAM GROSSMAN: Word of warning,
I'm getting over a cold.
So I'm really hoping that my
voice lasts the entire thing.
So I'll try to keep this short.
And also, full
disclosure, right now,
I'm a little bit
high on the "tussin."
And it turns out, I
just learned this right
before coming here,
that you're not
supposed to mix cold
medicine with whiskey.
I didn't know that, but
that train has sailed,
so we're going to
make the best of it.
I'm Adam Grossman.
I work for a tiny, little, two
person company called Dark Sky.
We make weather
prediction software.
We have an iOS app
called Dart Sky.
We have a weather API
for other developers.
And we make, more
recently, a weather website
called forecast.io.
If you want to
give us heartburn,
you can call it forecastio.
And it looks like
this on the desktop.
And on mobile, it
looks more like this.
That's the iPhone
version, and we really
tried hard to make
the mobile experience
feel like a native app.
So you save it to
your home screen.
In fact, we require
it, and that's
a very controversial decision.
It lives in your home screen.
It's got a little icon.
It fits in with
all the other apps.
And you launch it,
and you get something
that looks like a native app.
And when you slide
between views,
it's nice, smooth
animation, and we've even
got a nice, smoothly
animating radar map.
And the reason we did this,
and I don't recommend it
for all apps, but
the reason we did
this is because if you want
a weather app on your phone,
and you've got your
phone and you're out
and you want to
access the weather,
the last thing you want to
do is open your web browser,
navigate to some weather
website, enter your location,
and wait for it to load.
We just want to launch an
app and get the weather.
So if we had gone the
more traditional route,
I think a lot of people
just wouldn't use it,
so that's the reason
why we did it.
Now, a lot of ink
has been spilled
on the topic of mobile
web UI performance
and the bigger picture question
of what's the future of mobile?
Is it native apps, or
is it the mobile web?
And more recently,
the question has
been, why are mobile web apps so
crummy compared to native apps?
And they are.
If you take the
average mobile web
and you compare it to
the average native app,
it doesn't perform as well.
And of course, there
are always exceptions.
And if you do some Googling,
the general consensus,
if there is such a
thing on the web,
is that web apps are slow,
because JavaScript is slow.
There was a great article,
great blog post put out
by a guy named Drew
Crawford called,
"Why Mobile Web Apps are Slow."
And he did a comparison.
He showed benchmarks of
JavaScript versus native code.
And he found, of course,
that especially on mobile,
JavaScript is way
slower than native code.
And his conclusion
is that web apps
can't compete with native
apps, because they're
written in JavaScript.
And JavaScript has to
compete with, on iOS,
Objective C, which
is nice and fast.
On Android, it's generally Java.
Even BlackBerry,
presumably, Fortran.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GROSSMAN: And
all of these are fast,
and JavaScript is
comparatively much slower.
And that's why mobile
web apps are slow.
This is not true.
Web apps are not slow and crummy
because JavaScript is slow.
And the reason is really
simple-- graphical rendering
on the web does not
happen in JavaScript,
unless you're doing pixel by
pixel graphics on a canvas
element, nothing is being
drawn by JavaScript,
it's all being drawn by the
engine underneath it, which
has been heavily optimized.
And in fact, on iOS,
graphical rendering
is not done in
Objective C. It, most
of it, at least
the heavy lifting,
is offloaded onto the GPU.
And in fact, you can
prove this to yourself
with a little
thought experiment.
Imagine ripping out your GPU,
the little chip on your iPhone,
and being forced to do
everything in Objective C,
you would get a really
crummy experience.
So really, when it comes
to graphical performance,
it's not about JavaScript.
It's not about Objective
C. So it brings us
back to the original question,
why are mobile web apps so
crummy compared to native apps?
And to answer this
question, I think
I have to stop and give
you the two rules for how
to create performant
mobile web apps.
There's only two rules
you need to know.
And you only need to know these
two rules and nothing else.
So you might want to grab a pen.
The two rules for
performant mobile web
UI-- number one is to do
stuff that is performant.
Number two, second
rule, is avoid stuff
that performs poorly.
Now, before I continue, a
brief anecdotal interlude.
Growing up, I played baseball.
I was on the little league team.
And I had a little league
coach-- that's not him.
He was much fatter, and
that's the wrong sport.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GROSSMAN: And one day,
he gathered all of us around,
and he said, kids,
I'm going to tell you
the key to winning
any baseball game.
And of course, our ears
perked up, and we leaned up.
And he said, the key to
winning any baseball game
is to score more runs
than your opponent.
Thanks coach, you're
a really bad coach.
And it turns out,
he was a bad coach.
We lost most of the
games that year.
And I know that this rule
seems very similar, in spirit,
to my two rules for
performant mobile web UI.
But they're not.
They're not the
same, and I think
there's some interesting
things that we
can pull from this if
we really, really try.
The first thing to notice
is that, on the surface,
these two rules seem like
the same rule, just worded
in two different
ways so I can fill up
two points on the slide.
But really, I think
they're different.
And one of these
rules is much harder
to accomplish than
the other rule.
And if you were going to ask
someone who was just starting
up in web development
which rule was easy
and which rule was
hard, he would say,
the hard rule is the first one,
doing stuff that performs well,
finding the techniques
that you need.
Because there's a lot of
stuff you need to learn.
And learning is hard.
And you have to learn about
CSS transitions, and appcache,
and browser compatibility,
and all of that,
and that's really hard.
Meanwhile, rule
number two, avoiding
stuff that's easy-- that's
not doing something,
and not doing something
is really easy.
And you can just try things,
and if you look on your phone
and they don't
perform well, well,
you just don't include it.
And so that's really easy.
But I think true enlightenment
comes from the realization
that the situation is
reversed, that, in actuality,
the hard one is to avoid
stuff that performs poorly.
And the easy one is to do
stuff that performs well.
I need my water.
So I've been doing web
development for a while.
I was doing freelance
before I started Dart Sky.
But I'd never done any big
mobile project like Forecast.
And I didn't know,
really, where to start.
I didn't know what the
performance bottlenecks were.
So well, what I did
was I went to Google.
And I asked Google,
hey Google, how do I
make smooth animations
in mobile web apps?
And Google said, hey
here are some links
you might like to read, and
there's a whole bunch of them.
And the first thing you
learn is that if you're
going to make mobile
animations that are performant,
you should use CSS
transitions and transforms,
because they're hardware
accelerated and they're fast.
So I went back to Google
and I said, tell me
about CSS transforms
and transitions.
And it worked, even though
I spelled transitions wrong.
And suddenly, in
a weekend, I was
able to make my animations fast
and perfornant on my iPhone.
So then I went onto
the next thing.
I asked Google
about touch events.
And it told me
about touch events,
how to capture the event when
your figure touches the phone.
And suddenly, my smooth
animations were interactive.
You could interact with them.
And then I got
excited, and I went on.
And I asked Google
about appcache.
It is this thing
I'd heard about.
I always heard that it
was tough and confusing,
but you ask Google about
it, and it gives you
the links, the blog posts,
that you need to know.
And the appcache is
something that, well,
it tells the browser
to cache the app,
so the next time
you go to it, you
don't have to pull in all
of the HTML and JavaScript.
And suddenly,
you're interactive,
smooth animations
now loads quickly.
And finally, you want
to make it into an app
that you save to
your home screen.
So we ask Google, how do I save
mobile apps to the home screen?
Because that would
be really awesome.
And it tells you about
meta tags that you
can include in your page.
It's really easy, and when
you include those meta tags,
the Chrome disappears, the
Back button and what have you,
and you now have an app
that fills the screen.
And you also find about meta
tags for specifying icons.
So in very little work, in
about two weekends of Googling,
it's not tough.
In two weekends,
you can have an app
that lives on your home
screen, has an icon.
And when you launch the icon,
you get an app in full screen.
And its performant, and
it's great, and suddenly,
"The New York Times" is asking
you to give presentations.
And I think that was the
body from someone else.
That's not my body.
So learning the techniques
that perform well
is actually pretty
straightforward.
It doesn't take that long,
especially if you're already
a web developer.
And we like to think that
web development is difficult,
because it's our jobs.
It's our livelihoods.
But in reality, the hard
part is all the stuff
that happens behind the
scenes-- all the people that
work on the web kit team,
people at Google and Apple
and Mozilla who are making the
tools, doing the hard work,
to give us the handful of
tools to make mobile apps that
perform well.
So this is easy,
and I really think
that avoiding techniques
that perform poorly
is the hard part.
This is a little bit
counter intuitive,
because introducing crummy
performance on the web is
really an active endeavour.
The default is good performance.
So one of my favorite mobile
websites is Wikipedia,
and this is one of the
only content-heavy sites
where I actually prefer
their mobile site
over their desktop
site on my phone.
And it performs beautifully.
I think the most complicated
thing on this site
is an autocomplete
in the search.
But they don't try
to do anything fancy,
and because of that, they
get great performance.
It scrolls beautifully.
When you click on a sub
heading that's collapsed,
it just appears.
And no jittery
animations, because there
aren't any animations.
So really, good
performance is the default.
And when you come
across crummy websites,
it's because someone is
actively making it crummy.
And that's a very
perplexing thing.
One example is I
was reading a blog,
and it had a mobile
interface, and I
was scrolling through
it, vertically.
And as you're apt to do,
because your thumb is
on a weird swivel, I couldn't
scroll perfectly up and down.
And I managed to
go a bit sideways.
And all of a sudden,
this red semicircle
appeared, and it had this chunky
animated bitty, disgusting
loading screen.
The UI froze up, and then
a new blog post loaded.
And it was because
someone tried to get
fancy with a sweeping gesture
to load up new blog posts.
And it failed miserably.
And this is someone who was
not heeding rule number two.
Another example is
on the ESPN site.
I just saw this, where
you get a main headline,
and then you get one
sub-story, and a More link.
And when you click that
More link, it comes up,
and you get more articles.
And when you do that, it is
this chunky, horrible animation
that's a few frames a second.
And doing this in a
way that is smooth
takes no extra work than doing
it in a way that's not smooth.
And this is a major website.
And they've failed to
heed rule number two.
There are design
examples of this, too.
Any time you see
content that spills over
or a nav that spills
over your content,
as someone who has actively
incorporated crummy design.
My favorite example
is this website.
You go here, and I exaggerated
it by putting it in landscape,
but you have browser Chrome
on the top and the bottom.
And then they've introduced
a header and a footer that's
always there, fixed positioning.
And I don't understand
the Share links.
It's as if you're going to get
halfway through the article,
and you just can't wait
to share it on Twitter.
So it's there, and
again so it's not
just performance in terms
of making smooth animations,
it's also the design, too.
And this is someone
actively making
the design worse by doing this.
The rest of the site
looks really nice,
but this one aspect.
So why do we do it?
If it's an active
thing, it seems
like it should be
really easy to avoid.
And it seems to be a bigger
problem on the mobile web
than in native apps.
And why is that?
I think this rule,
avoid stuff that
performs poorly, I think the key
difference between native apps
and mobile web apps
is that this rule is
really easy to break on the web.
And it's really hard to break
when you make native apps.
So what do I mean by this?
On the web, you're given all
sorts of ways to do things.
And generally, the
way that you've
learned them, when you're
just making static content,
is not the way you
should do things
when you're trying to make
dynamic animations that
perform well.
So one example is, say
you make a static page,
and you want to position
something absolutely,
so you give it a CSS
position absolute,
and you set its top
and left attributes,
and you put it somewhere.
And now, say you want
to make it dynamic,
you want to animate it.
I think the first thing we
all do is we load up jQuery,
and we animate the top and
left attributes in jQuery.
And when you try it,
historically, that
has given really poor
performance on mobile.
You should really be
using CSS transitions.
Meanwhile, on native apps,
and this is especially true
in iOS-- as far as native apps
go, I'm only an iOS developer.
But I imagine this
is true in Android.
Apple makes it really hard to
do things that perform poorly.
Apple has a UI kit,
and core animation,
and there's all sorts of juicy
things you can do with this.
And you can't find anything
in there that performs poorly.
If you try to break it and
try to do these things,
it's really hard to do that.
Because Apple has
it locked down.
And they only give you
tools that perform well.
And one big example of this
is it is possible to make,
of course, iOS apps
that don't perform well.
And the biggest
way to do this is
to do custom drawing operations.
And also in the iOS world, there
are things called UI views,
and UI views, you can think of
them as divs in the HTML world.
They're just generic,
rectangle containers
that you can put stuff in.
And you can implement
an optional method
on them called drawrect.
It's optional, you usually
don't want to use it.
But when you implement
it, it turns a UI view
into, essentially, a
canvas element, where
you can do canvas drawing to it.
And actually, the syntax is
very similar to the syntax
for a canvas drawing, presumably
because canvas was originally
developed by Apple.
So Apple cares so much
about you not using this
that they'll actually
put this optional method.
When you go into Xcode
and you create a file,
they'll put this method here.
They'll comment it out,
and in the comment,
they tell you not to use it.
And I think the only
reason they actually
put this here is so
that they could tell you
that it adversely
affects performance.
And so I think this is
the biggest difference
between the native
world and the web world
is that just it's really
hard to break this rule.
So where do we go from here?
How do we avoid making
crummy web apps?
I think the biggest thing,
more so than on native apps,
is discipline.
We need to take
great care that we
don't introduce
poor performance.
Some things to watch out
for are-- well, the biggest
thing to watch out for,
and this is something
that I fall for all the
time, is falling in love
with a bad idea.
So maybe you have
an idea-- presumably
the person who
made that blog post
with the really
awful swiping, he
fell in love with the idea of
swiping to get back and forth
between blog posts.
For me, it's been
a lot of things.
I wanted to implement
a thing in Forecast
for deleting saved locations,
where when you clicked
the Delete button, the
thing jumps up, crinkles up,
gets thrown away into a
trash bin, and fades out.
And it's really seductive to
fall in love with an idea.
And when you test it,
it will often work,
because you're testing
in a environment that's
not a real world environment.
And it turns out, when
you actually implement it,
when it's actually interacting
with other things on the page,
sometimes it fails.
And if you fall in
love with a bad idea,
it's sometimes really hard to
let it go, and it stays in.
And sometimes you
don't listen when
your friends try to
talk you out of it.
And they say that
idea's no good for you.
And that's fine.
Experiment, fool
around a little bit,
we're young, but
don't settle down
too easily if it turns out
that the idea turns out
to be no good for you.
I don't know why I
used this picture
of an example of a couple
that's no good for each other.
They look really happy.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM GROSSMAN:
Yeah, if one of them
decides to change their
hair before the other.
Another thing to
avoid is, of course,
designer-developer disconnect.
And this is true,
tends to be true,
at larger organizations, where
you have a designer designing
something or a team of
designers and they hand it
down to developers.
And time was you could design
something in Photoshop,
because websites were static.
And developers
could implement it,
and sometimes they had to do
disgusting things like chop it
up into a grid of images and
use tables, but it worked.
But now, especially
on the mobile web,
websites are dynamic,
they're animated.
And it's really hard to
design for that, especially
in Photoshop.
So designers may have
these great ideas
for how to do things, how
to interact with things.
And when it comes time
to actually develop them,
it doesn't work.
And I think that, very often,
developers don't speak up
about it, and it stays in there.
So I think the way to avoid this
is to really-- developers, take
ownership in any design work
and any app you working on.
I don't know any organization
where a developer couldn't
go back to the designers,
and even back to management,
and say, this is a great
idea, but it turns out,
when we actually implement
it, it doesn't work.
So there needs to be
this cyclical process
of development.
Another thing to avoid is
one platform preference.
I am an iPhone guy.
I love my iPhone.
I will never switch to Android.
I have a bunch of Android
phones, and I never use them.
I have a Firefox OS
device, and I really
want the Firefox OS
device to be great.
But it's not that great.
And so I'm really
about iOS, and this
is to the severe
detriment of Forecast.
Because it works way better on
iOS than it does on Android.
So this is something to avoid.
And this is the lesson
I need to learn.
But I haven't.
I can put it in a slide.
The next thing to avoid is
what I call test blindness.
And when you develop an app,
as you progress in development,
you're constantly using
it, you're constantly
interacting with it, you're
loading it on your phone.
And pretty soon, you
learn how to avoid
interacting with it in
a way that breaks it.
You know all the
little, hidden gotchas,
and subconsciously,
you avoid it.
And I do this all the time.
I'll do something, and
I'll think it has no bugs.
And then I'll hand
it to my wife,
and the very first thing
she does is break it.
She'll double tap
on things you're not
supposed to double tap on.
She'll slide when you're
not supposed to slide,
and it completely falls apart.
And so the way I know that I'm
falling for test blindness is
when I show a new app to
someone new on my phone,
and instead of handing
it to them, I load it up,
and I show it to them.
And I show them how I'm
interacting with it.
Isn't this a great thing?
And I don't hand over my phone.
And I've seen other
developers do this, too,
when they're working on
something, especially when it's
in beta.
And if you're afraid to
hand over your phone,
if you try to show people it
by you interacting with it,
then you're probably
succumbing to test blindness.
So these are the
things to avoid,
and there's lots of
other things to avoid.
But it really
boils down to this.
The only way that we're going
to compete with native apps
is through unflinching
diligence to keep crumminess out
of our apps.
Native app developers
have it easy.
They got it by
default, but we have
to spend every waking
minute that we're developing
a mobile web app and make sure
that the crumminess doesn't
get introduced.
Because once it's there, it's
really hard to get rid of it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM GROSSMAN: One quick thing.
I do have one
anecdotal postscript
that has nothing to do with the
mobile web app UI performance.
I had one slide in
here where I was
going to talk about how web
development is so easy that you
could teach my
grandmother to do it.
So here is my grandmother,
presumably rocking out
in BBEdit, listening
to 5by5 podcasts.
Actually, this is
not my grandmother.
I had to do a Google Image
search for old ladies
on a computer.
And there's a lot of images
of old ladies on computers.
But one really strange
phenomenon is even more
than there are old
ladies on computers,
there are a bunch of old
ladies smoking cigars.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GROSSMAN: I don't
understand this phenomenon.
It's all over.
The web is filled with
old lady smoking cigars.
This one's my favorite.
It's an explicable, and this is
maybe the Robitussin talking,
but I love that
we live in a world
where such a thing is possible.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM GROSSMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]